this is a production of Cornell
University
and it's really really nice to be back
in Ithaca and because all the work that
I'm going to tell you today started like
one floor up I think in this corner in
Steve's lap and yiping and I were
postdocs there around the same time so
that's where we connect it's wonderful
to have met with some of you already
this morning I look forward to meeting
others this afternoon and I had a great
time with The Graduate students over
lunch so it's been a nice visit so I'm
gonna start off this uh to thank
actually
um the the team that we've assembled
over the last
well it started in 2015 was funded by a
plan genome Grant
and it it had number of of uh of copies
on this project including
um a group in Valencia and in Spain uh
that provided The Germ Pleasant that I'm
gonna talk about today uh then uh in
Massachusetts with Anna casedo who did a
lot of The evolutionary analysis
together with hamit razifert who was a
postdoc here I don't think he's here but
I did I think he's left but he's about
he followed up after Anna's lap being
post-doc in Margaret Frank's lab of
course we always worked with Lucas and
Nama here at Cornell or at Boyce
Thompson Institute on depositing all our
research at the Seoul genomics Network
website database and we've always worked
with Faye and we had a really productive
collaboration with Faye and Ying Wang at
Mississippi State although he just
recently moved to to University of
Florida where a paper that we published
last year on the evolution of small rnas
non-coding rnas in in tomato
in tomato so the evolution of
populations of small rnas
I've worked for many years with Sophia
Visa at the College of Worcester that's
where I was for 14 years while I had was
at Ohio State and she's always been my
Outreach component and she still is on
on current project and some of the work
that I'll present today was actually
done done by her group and then last but
not least of course at the University of
Florida I collaborate extensively with
Denise steaman in Harry Cleese lab in
particular with Elizabeth Frick
who worked on volatile analysis on this
project and in my lab at the University
of Georgia I worked on the morphology
initially on fruit size particularly and
specifically Alexis Ramos is a picture
of him in the right-hand corner with an
outstanding Master student who did who
did all the initial hard work on this
project uh the research I'm going to
talk about today was done by by
Elizabeth Frick or Libby Frick and then
two people in my lab Lara Pereira a
postdoc uh who recently went back to uh
Europe and a graduate student
whose work I'm actually going to present
today and he is about to graduate
although I wish he never graduates
because he's too valuable
so what is this collection what's the
Hidden Gem part about so this varitome
collection are kind of uh hinted to uh
about that already about the name so we
call it the varitome collection it
consists of a number of fully wild
species accessions the salon elepholium
um about 20 accessions so it's not not
extensive but then the biggest part of
this collection is comprised of solanum
like a person sarasi for me or SLC which
ranges uh with successions they arrange
in fruit size from fruits that are as
small as being Penelope volume to as
large as fully cultivated tomato and we
have approximately 120x sessions of SLC
and then a few uh very ancestral SLL
fully cultivated types that were
collected in Mexico by by the way by the
group in Valencia
yeah so um what you can do this is work
done by Hamid what you can do is uh you
can determine the relationship uh uh
among these sub populations based on
whole genome sequences and you see
there's a phylogenetic tree here uh
which I don't want you to get too
um too much uh carried away well you
cannot read this anyway but these are
the different colors or actually
different subgroups of pimpanellifolium
and so the peepin elephone from
northerner northern Ecuador is most
closely related to the SLC from Ecuador
then we have here the soc from Peru SLC
from Summer 10 and then here in this
lighter orange is uh SLC that are
transitional from Central America moving
out of Ecuador uh in towards Mexico and
then we have here a cluster of SLC from
Mexico and last but not least the fully
cultivated types the SLL and so if you
do diversity analysis on this subpopular
patients you see that the what's in the
boxed area here is that the SLC from
Ecuador and the SLC from Peru have as
much diversity as uh the the fully wild
relatives of the Pimpin elephone from
Peru and from Ecuador so this is
obviously a great source
um for for at least genetic variation
and hopefully also trade variation
and you can see that the SLL here at the
end the genetic diversity is much much
lower
so this is very generalized what are the
traits that uh uh we we focus on during
uh you know
during during domestication we did in
the past you know and which are still
very important traits for crop
Improvement and many of you know I have
worked a lot on fruit shape and fruit
size so that would be this category here
produce shape and morphology but today's
talk is going to be more on the flavor
and and Aroma and so what is aroma and I
I'm sure that Harry is given talks here
and he he would present a paper a figure
like this
um so when you uh taste anything that
you eat uh you you you're you're the
sensory neurons on on your the sensory
receptors in on your tongue they sense
the sugars and the acids but what what
you're also experiencing is the
volatiles that are released uh as you're
eating the the product either through
directly through the nose or through
your throat and that's the focus of of
our research is actually the volatile
Aroma that are released by ripe tomatoes
and so I I decided to put a few pictures
of it in for the graduate students
because all sounds really fun but
there's a lot of hard work uh involved
in getting the data that I'm showing you
today this is from a field site in
Florida in Northern Florida uh it's an
hour north of Gainesville so this is
where Denise tiemann grows all their
tomatoes and here we are collecting
tomatoes and you see they are just so
overgrown they sometimes are taller than
some of the graduate students the plants
are growing incredibly wild and it's
sometimes a little bit of a chore to
find the fruits but we do and then we
take the fruits to for the volatile
analysis we take the fruits to Denise's
lab here a couple of pictures of from
their Labs so they're in the upper
left-hand corner is uh is Zach who's
weighing the tomatoes sorting them and
weighing them and then cutting them in
smaller pieces they then on the picture
on the right you see Denise there and
you're seen from my lab stuffing them
into glass tubes and putting rubber
stoppers on the end and then in the
bottom uh left corner is where they get
hooked up to
a system where inert air is blown over
over the tube over the tomatoes in the
tube and then at the end it's not shown
here but at the end of this stopper here
there's a column and and the volatiles
are actually uh
accumulate on that column and then after
an hour of the of the the fruits here
emitting the volatiles we collected The
Columns and then we elude the volatiles
they then I run on a gcms for a group to
get a general to generate a chromatogram
like this and so that's uh it's fairly
labor intensive to do all this volatile
analysis and then the chromatograms
often are also hand edited uh for
accuracy
and so there are major volatile Pathways
in tomato a lot of the work has been
done in Denise and Harry's lab and so
this is a figure that's modified from
one of their reviews and so uh there's a
branch chain amino acid derived
volatiles there's the acetate Ester
derived volatiles there's the
lipid-derived volatiles there's the
phenopropanoids
um and then there are the phenolics and
then last but not least carotenoids also
uh release uh you know corruption or
derived volatiles are also very
important
so the many different Pathways that
contribute to the volatile Aroma of the
fruit
and so from this collection we obtained
information about 60 different or more
than 60 different volatiles and they
fall into different classes you know
there's so many acetate Esters were
collected Etc and then what we did is we
looked at the genetic uh uh the
different subgroups and and Quantified
the different uh volatiles from the
different Pathways and what you can see
on the panel a is that you see that in
green is the pimpanellifolium volatile
profile in the principal component spot
and then in blue circled already uh
ancestral SLL so they are they are
separated the SLC in red are just are
are either as similar as pimpy or as
similar as the SLL but very clearly what
you see here there's a shift in volatile
profile from the heirloom slash
domesticated type so more modern
material that's circled in Gray and then
in panel B you can see a different
volatile groups and and how they
accumulate for example in green there's
the lipid the lipid-derived volatiles in
the soc from Summer 10 which is a region
in in Peru are have a very much
increased over that of the fully uh wild
species so there's enormous variation in
volatile accumulation that is different
subgroups from fully wild to SLC to
fully cultivated
so of course if you have genome sequence
we can do a genome-wide Association
study with this we did it specifically
with the vaditone collection because our
our sequences were good and this is work
from Manoj in my lab and uh we used uh
initially used just Snips and an older
version of the Tomato genome and later
we went back and redid the analysis also
interrogating indels and structural
variants and this is where I want to
point out that actually structural
variant least was compiled by uh by
Sophia Visa by using lumpy and then
various other ways of
um assessing whether this structural
variants were real or novels you get a
lot of art false positives but that's
actually our original structural variant
list and then you create a Manhattan
plot and we keep it separate right now
for Snips in Belgian as well and in
total of 652 variants variety identified
for many of the volatiles not all
and so that's a lot and this is what it
looks like when you plot all these
variants on the genomes it's basically
everywhere so I find a part of the
genome that's not
um not corresponding or not contributing
to any of the volatiles volatile
production so they're coded here by
caller which indicates which class
they're in or by Circle or triangle or
Square and that means if it's an Intel
snip or a structural variant or SV
and so now we wanted to reduce the
number of loci because what do you do
when you have 652 variants so one way to
do that was to establish establish a LD
and a genome-wide we uh the average is
we estimated that at 200 KB
um and but of course uh there's also
regions of the central mirror about the
ldus would be much larger and regions in
the eugromatic part that are where the
LD is much smaller but we took an
estimate of of 200 KB so a snip if
there's 200 or you know 150 KB away
there's another snip we consider that to
be one
um one Locus and that if you then Focus
only on the euchromatic variants then uh
it narrows it down to about 100 loci
that collapsed because there's either
several variants in that region or the
multiple variant uh sorry multiple
volatiles mapping to that same region
and then there's still 184 low sided
display only single evidence so one
variant and one volatile
so we in in the meantime we had also uh
started to create biparental mapping
populations initially primarily to map
fruitway genes and and clone them but
Denise I would always look at the
parental volatile profiles like oh these
are cool these are kind of segregate for
volatile X Y and Z so we have four
populations
a reasonable size for an F2 uh we got a
lot of variants because we uh we're
using GBS to genotype and then we did
composite interval mapping in these four
populations to to identify a number of
qtls in uh from these four by parental
mapping populations and so we found that
enough of all those qtls found from uh
from the composite interval mapping or
the Sim we found it about half actually
overlap with G was low size so that's
helpful
so now I want to mention uh what we're
doing now and it's still a work in
progress uh but we're of course there
are so many loci to select from we still
have nearly 300 from G Was Alone
um of course uh the one reason not to
follow up on the locus if it's already
cloned so there were a few uh genes uh
that were identified that are already
cloned so we're not following up on
those so we want to look at novoloci and
then we took several factors into
account and not it's it's it's uh it's
kind of a hybrid of what was more
important but one of them was evidence
so if you have uh only one snip that is
barely significantly associated with a
uh a volatile and it's only one volatile
that shows up uh uh at that Locus and
well maybe that's a less
um well it's probably important but
let's not focus on that so looking at
evidence meaning like do we get a snip
and another snip maybe several
structural variants associated with that
Locus and or are there multiple
volatiles
linked to that logo so it's a production
of of the levels of of multiple
volatiles uh controlled by that Locus so
and then looking at the significance too
so let's say we get one snip and it's
incredibly significant uh just because
it's only one snip We're Not Gonna toss
it aside we certainly would like to
follow up on that Locus as well and if
there is overlap with the mapping
population it is very helpful because
then we can have other genetic uh ways
to confirm the locus
so uh so so we narrow down our the
number of low side we want to follow up
on and then Manoj developed this
pipeline to make an uh attempt at least
to do some candidate Gene identification
without going through each Locus bio
well by you know by end one you know two
300 KB one uh Gene at the time so what
he did he created a pipeline that would
interrogate the expression profile of
these genes in public databases as well
as the biochemical annotation and with
that the last part the biochemical
annotations where Denise always comes in
and and helps us out and so then you end
up with a set of loci that have
candidate genes and but there's also a
lot that do not have candidate genes
so I'm going to give you an example
about the acetate Ester pathway and the
two genes that were already cloned many
years ago are a carboxyl esterase on
chromosome one and an alcohol acyl
transformation chromosome eight and you
see the pathway there's pretty simple as
a feedback loop where the carboxylase
Rays
conversations into alcohols and the a81
does the opposite so do we find a cxe1
and a81 in our G bus and yes we do
they're they're indicated here on the
slide and you can see there's a lot of
variants still
there's a lot of other variants that are
underlying unknown genes so here you
have one example for example where
there's a lot of evidence you see
there's like a snip and an indel and and
then potentially also multiple volatiles
from the estate as the pathway because
it's a lot of dots there
and so that one actually shows up here
uh also circled in Red so that's a a
possible uh candidate Gene underlying uh
volatile production at that Locus and
here you see an example of of the list
of candidate genes that we've identified
in purple highlighted in purple is a
givas Locus that overlaps with a
composite interval mapping Locus or a by
parental cross Locus so that one on the
top the alcohol dehydrogenase is a
really good candidate Gene
so now another example is the
phenopropenoid pathway and I'll tell you
a little bit more about that so in that
case there is already multiple genes
identified
um five in total I'm gonna talk more
about the methyl salicylate uh pathway
uh in the next part of the second part
of my talk but the genes cloned are uh
are already indicated here so salicylic
acid gets converted by salicylic acid
methyl transferase into methyl
salicylate and methyl salicylate then
gets conjugated by glycocil transferases
into a DI glucoside molecule and that
then gets converted further to a
trisectoride conjugate by another
glyphosol transferase called nsgt1
there's a lot of acronyms non-smokey
glucosal transferase but that's the
pathway of salicylic acid so a lot of
these genes are very important in this
pathway and have been clone do they show
up in our jivas some of them so mess for
sure and that's uh the gene that was
recently cloned uh by Libby in in Harry
and Denise's lab so this is why she
actually focused on that there was a she
was a variant uh right on top of the of
the locus and then nsgt-1 is identified
as well as the salicylic acid metal
transferase but the other two genes
there's no uh variants associated with
those
and so the candidate genes for the
fennel proponoid uh uh uh
volatiles at the Divas low-siders again
one that is common in both uh the G was
and by parental mapping population and
that's a uh it's annotated as a new DX
Hydro loss hydrolase 17 and it's known
from other systems to be involved in
systemic acquired resistance so that's
actually phenopropanoids are part of
that pathway
and again a couple of other ones uh
including an interesting uh an E8 like
uh Gene on chromosome 3.
I think Jim probably knows that one
so how can breeders use this knowledge
uh and or other way to put it like how
can we harness this genetic diversity uh
and and towards crop Improvement then
have to give a couple of uh reminders
here because uh the one thing
um this this research is is cool to do
and but how how practical is it at this
point well we need to know first what
are the Improvement alleles have we can
figure that out from the data that we
have a little bit more study and we'll
be good uh we also have to know about
the desirability of that particular
volatile so a lot of that work has been
done uh in the nice and Harry's lab in
the past so we do have some idea about
volatiles that are generally liked and
volatiles that are generally not liked
but then there's also something about
the quantity and the combination of the
other volatiles that third bullet point
uh it's uh you know it's you have to
combine uh you have to think about the
combination of all the volatiles that
are accumulating
um and so you know Aroma is actually
quite complex X we can make it simple to
split them up in different Pathways but
then you know if you have a highly liked
volatile and then you're like okay I'm
gonna now select for the highest level
uh in my next breeding line is it's then
still you know liked is it or maybe got
too much of it
um so that that is something to consider
so we're still a ways off for uh uh to
to to to use this information for crop
Improvement we have to realize that
there are other things coming in play
and the last but not least what tastes
good to some people in tomato and other
other fruits and vegetables it might not
be good for everyone not everybody likes
the same type of tomato so it's it's
still a ways off but um I will show give
you an example of how I think we can we
can make use of this data to some extent
so here I'm coming back to methyl
salicylate this is the chemical
structure and it's produced in the pheno
Pro openoid pathway and it's a really
important pathway in tomato
it's responsible for an aroma called
Wintergreen and that probably doesn't
sound very appealing in tomato it's not
that's why people do not like it it's
it's not associated with It's associated
with low lighting so this is again work
done in in Harry and Denise's lab but it
is quite important for pathogen
signaling and stress signaling by the
plant so it's not uh it's not a pathway
we want to just eliminate that would not
be good so this is again the
biosynthesis and the conjugation of
methyl salicylate I kind of alluded to
earlier uh is the salicylic acid methyl
transferase the UDP lupusil transferases
that converted to a diet
saccharide and then the nsdt-1 it
converts it to a tricycle rights and
that is irreversible if nsdt1 is not
present then the dichloposide conjugate
can be converted back to methyl
salicylate and then the methyl esterase
is the focus of the this second part of
the talk uh come into play and they can
convert uh methyl salicylate back to
salicylic acid
so methyl salicylate levels are uh are
varying in the bodycon collection but
not extremely most varieties or most
accessions I should say these are not
varieties most accessions produce very
low levels
um even the fully wild species produce
low levels but there are a few
accessions that produce fairly high
levels as you see in panel a then in
panel B you can see uh the levels from
the of methyl salicylate produced by the
different subpopulation and you see that
the SP from northern Ecuador produces
significantly higher levels in the other
uh pimpanelifolium clusters and also
then it produces much higher levels than
SLC from Mexico for example
so the SP from northern Ecuador is
particularly producing high levels of
methyl salicylate and SLC Ecuador as
well
so
um I alluded to earlier there was a
major jivas uh variant very significant
he was a variant right on the on the
locus I think it has also a structural
variant in here somewhere
um and I'll get to structural variant
variation at the locus in a minute so
um we found four different genes mess
one through Mass four
and what Libby did and also with some
work done in our lab we created a a mess
one knockout uh in the money maker
background a Libby here shows this in
the Brandywine background if you knock
out mess one by crispr you get
significantly higher levels of methyl
salicylate and that's what you're
expecting if you let me actually go back
to the pathway if you
um
if you knock out mess one you will start
accumulating methyl salicylate
so you uh yeah that's that's what we're
expecting so you knock out mess one uh
we get much higher levels of methyl
salicylate so mess one is quite
important and so what we did in my lab
is is looking at the hepatype diversity
and this is was for us uh quite uh
astonishing because this is only based
on structural variance and uh that alone
and the basis of this was again with the
data set that Sophia Visa created and
later we confirmed it with the Oxford
nanopore sequences from a Zach lipmann's
group but we found up to nine different
Apple types in Red fruited Tomato alone
and it's not that the wild species all
are part of one haplotype actually SP
found you know SP accessions are found
in in I think four or five or six
haplotypes so even SP itself the fully
wild relative there's there's a lot of
genetic variation
now this uh this graph is uh uh can be
interpreted as that the darker blue
boxes are uh
to best of our knowledge they look like
full length coding no weird you know
premature stop-codone genes we think
they're functional uh if they're light
blue uh there's there's a couple of
mutations in there including premature
subcodones or a frame shift that uh uh
lead to uh probably truncated protein
and probably these are non-functional
and then the the the the pink one or
peach color I guess uh mess three that's
an unusual one there's only one
haplotype where mesh three is full
length but all the other haplotypes that
have some S3 they're actually truncated
and there are shorter versions of that
protein but Libby has shown actually
that Nest three the shorter version has
still some activity but it's not as good
as mes1 so we think mess three in the
pink is still functional
um yeah
so
um now we can of course associate the
the mess and the nsdg-1 hypnotized with
methyl salicylate levels and uh and this
is for uh mes1 and panel a where you see
haplotype 2 is particularly uh you know
the accessions belonging to carrying
that haplot I've produced particular
high levels of methyl salicylate and
significantly higher for example than
hypotypes six and seven
and then for nsdt1 based on structural
variance alone uh this was work we did
with Mike Mike shots and Michael launch
and and Zach Libman in the paper cited
here
um this the the you can find up to five
different hippo types of nsdt one of
which three uh one to three are
considered functional because there's
still a functional protein there and
four doesn't does uh does have I I
doesn't have has one copy sort of but
it's not functioning as well in aprotype
5 is definitely a knockout where both
copies of the gene are eliminated
so now of course we can look at the
interaction between uh the mess and the
nsdt1 Apple types and uh here you see uh
the the nine different Apple types of
mass one those are the the nine uh
um uh squares and then in color whether
they have nst21 hypotype uh one two
three or four or five and you see here
haplotype two the one that leads to
significantly higher levels of methyl
salicylate the levels increase further
if you have an inactive version of nsdt1
contrary here with type 6 and 7 for for
mesh you see that the there's there's
still a they're accumulating very low
levels of methyl salicylate no matter
what uh the uh the locus or the alleles
at nsgt1
so
um just to remind you here's the pathway
again if you knock out mess one and you
knock out nsgt1 you really are able to
increase the levels of methyl salicylate
a lot
so
um I showed you this slide this slide
before uh to the best of our knowledge
um uh you know the blue indicates that
uh the blue collar indicates it is a
functional Gene and most of these
haplotypes seem to be able to produce a
functional copy of the mes1 Gene and
um but you know I showed you too that
haplotype 2 is particularly uh uh you
know associated with high levels of
methyl salicylate suggesting that that
hypotype is actually non-functional but
the gene mess one still looks functional
so what's going on well then we did some
expression analysis just q r to PCR
where on on the top you see about six or
seven accessions that belong to helper
type 6 and you see the levels of methyl
salicylate are really low
um and then hepatype 2 is below is also
six successions see that the levels of
methyl salicylate are very high and you
can clearly see uh by eye here that in
hypnotype 2 None of the mesh genes are
even expressed uh where whereas in
haplotype six uh three of the four mesh
genes are expressed and particularly
mess one but also Mass three so that
explains why Mass 2 is is knocked out
even though we don't know why the genes
are just not expressed
but uh yeah
and so then of course we know where all
these accessions were collected uh they
were collected in South America and uh
Central America in Mexico and so here is
a graph that shows uh uh where the
different HEPA types of of the mess
Locus were collected so again the the
first uh block here
um is is uh is the five or six different
HEPA types of of SP so it's a lot of
variation in Sp alone uh and the darker
blue indicates the hypotype 2 the
non-functional haplotype you see that
that's quite well selected against uh
during domestication and it's it's it's
rarely found in in cultivated or well
not in our collection but also not in
ancestral SLL and instead in the zestro
SLL you have hypotype six and seven that
are very prevalent
and then it is also color coded on the
map basically so the blue haplotype 2
you can see it's found here in Ecuador
along the coast but also in the
mountains
and this is the situation for nsgt1
where uh the functional uh appetypes one
through three are found in all the SPX
sessions but then during domestication
more and more uh we we didn't select for
the most functional hypotypes at this
Locus and so the the least functional
the one that clearly uh uh
non-functionals have prototype five and
you also find these in roughly the same
uh area uh in in Ecuador and then you
can superimpose that with levels of
methyl salicylate that were found in
these uh these accessions in Florida and
you see the accessions that produce high
levels of methyl salicylate are found
again in Ecuador corresponding to a
non-functional allele of nsdt1 and a
non-functional allele of mess
so as I'm wrapping up this presentation
um I just uh wanted to uh you know
summarize all our findings with mess and
mess and nsgt1 we present a range of
alleles in red fruited tomatoes
um and more more than I thought was was
uh was possible but volatiles I guess
has enormous variation out there so we
selected it very much for a functional
allele at mess uh and a non-functional
allele at nsgt1 during domestication I
don't know why that was
um I could I could hypothesize but this
is the opposite of what was found in Sp
I don't know why that is either
interesting questions uh to to think
about and so
um but what I was told by one of my
former graduate students who works for
Bayer now he said now but most are Elite
tomato varieties are all carrying the
functional allele of NSG you want so
breeders in companies have clearly
selected for a functional allulated
Locus to keep the levels of methyl
salicylate low
so the geographic distribution of course
of these alleles in Ecuador suggest that
there's maybe a need for accessions
in Ecuador to carry higher levels of
methyl salicylate perhaps to fend off uh
insect herbivores or or other diseases
um yeah or other diseases it might be
important for the life cycle of the
plant
and so with that I'll just finish up
with this uh slide again thanking the
the folks in the lab in particular uh my
my graduate student Manors who's pretty
much his entire thesis was presented
here today and uh and Lara Pereira who's
done a lot of work with on that project
and then Libby and Denise at the
University of Florida and with that I am
happy to take any questions
and I usually go over time it's like wow
this is the first time I'm like early
apologize I didn't want to get out of it
yeah
how often does this situation with MES
happen with other volatile
um clouds of traits in the scale like
it's very common is it pretty frequent
where they're kind of diversity related
to the agronomic like
um
I guess maybe storage or light
capabilities
so your question is how often do you
find this level of variation at the
locus how often do bowels attract
negatively or maybe foreign
oh
well good question uh so how often
what's the link between uh you know good
tasting tomato and yield I think that's
the translation
yeah so
um
well there is a correlation and uh you
know you can show that larger Tomatoes
tend to have
less flavor and and the fruit quality is
going down and actually Denise has shown
that
in their work uh the idea is though that
um that that's possibly caused by uh the
lack of knowledge of where the loci are
that you need to keep to have a good
tasting tomato
so just to you know to analyze volatiles
uh you have to have specialized
equipment it's very time consuming and
you need a really good biochemist on the
project to to figure it out because the
grammatogram I showed you was the best
ever now most of them are not that clear
it's like there's a lot of
Denise what is this how do I measure
this or how do I quantify you know this
one is all shifted or whatever so it is
actually quite uh it's not easy to to
quantify the volatiles so having said
that you know the volatiles that uh
we're looking at are produced in such
low quantities that uh we we don't think
it act that that's it's it's it's
creating such a drain on the plant
so we think that we can you know we
should be able to create better tasting
tomatoes without uh compromising yields
we shall see
yeah have you tried the imputing you
know all the exactly uh and vibrators uh
Apple types onto your panels and redoing
the association
yeah so that its question is about uh
you know using actually that those
re-sequence genomes and do G was again
um
we I know so you know what we do now I
mean I don't want to minimize the impact
of that data set that's that created
because it's enormous every time we're a
new Locus first thing is like what's the
genome structure in well we don't always
have the parent sequence but something
related what's what is possible and uh
you know a lot of volatile loci actually
are uh are structural variants so we we
get very quickly then an idea whether
you know uh whether it's a structure
variant likely to be causative
um yeah no yeah we could we could redo
the analysis
um we we have everything set up in the
lab that all these reference genomes
like 14 or so are all there we can we
can always align the short reads to any
reference genome because if you take a
pimpy and you align it to the Hinds you
have a lot of snips we have a very nice
pimpy genome so it's it's helpful to
figure out what's going on what we do it
more one-on-one at the time based one
Mobius at the time so yeah I think we
can we could do that
it would cost just time right
my student wants to graduate
[Laughter]
um I think salicylic acid can prime
plant immune responses
uh and and so it kind of has a hormonal
function that way and I'm wondering how
often you are looking at these different
volatiles and come across something that
seems to have some kind of hormonal
function
yeah so uh salicylic acid and methyl
salicylate are definitely in the
phenoproponopatha is really important in
defense signaling
um
whether other volatiles are important in
defense uh
I don't know that answer I do know when
the plan when the yeah the plant is
diseased we get a different volatile
profile so we have to be really careful
with also when we are in the lab and
selecting the fruit has to be like
perfect fruit not too ripe because if
they overripe they have another volatile
profile so I I actually don't know the
answer to to your question
um
yeah
it's I actually we're creating Knockouts
in the different mesh genes wanted and I
I really wonder uh what you know
hopefully working in the future with
plantologists or so to figure out if you
knock out mesh 3 you know is the plant
more susceptible to
I know some pathogen infection and it's
possible there's some anecdotal
references about methyl salicylate
levels in in Roots and then reducing uh
CIS nematode so you know it's it's it's
possibly important the methyl salicylate
and Harry once said well the levels of
methyl salicylate have gone up in um in
the tomatoes that we essayed here and he
he thought it was because you know if
you have a little higher levels of
methyl salicylate you have a little bit
better disease resistance just general
resistance and that's possibly what
breed is selected for I I possibly yeah
have you ever eaten one of these
Wintergreen Tomatoes no but it's like
it's like I'm I'm yeah minty is what
people say I don't know what it is I
maybe I don't want to know but we've
we've tasted all these Tomatoes we uh I
have one postdoc with like but we would
this was the first year didn't she stop
it she would taste every tomato that we
got from the field like oh that's good
oh that's bad
foreign
[Music]
I think
um
because it's also preference so there
was a study done in Europe I don't know
a decade ago and yeah yeah well and the
Italians like this type of tomato and
the Dutch people like another type and
they were not even overlapping so I've
heard also anecdotal stories of like you
know undergraduates in the lab like oh
this really tastes like a good tomato
but it was considered a poor tasting
tomato what is a tomato that you can buy
in the grocery stores and people are
familiar your young people are familiar
with that type of flavor so I I don't
think that's so possible to create one
um one Aroma one
um
yeah one one type of Aroma for for
everyone but then it's it's also very uh
it's not so stable right if the produce
are longer in the store you know they're
gonna lose some of their flavor over
time
yeah oh I see I think they have the
light bulbs to change their color
they've read that
yeah
there's a lot of
true
um I don't know I think I uh perhaps in
the future yeah
I don't think I'll I'll be working on
that
Jim
so I understood so with Nets you
basically got a collection of alleles
that are encoding functional genes think
about expression irrigation
and so and your expression data is that
all fruit yeah so I didn't explain so
the expression data that I showed was
just from Ripe fruit collected from the
field so yeah I'm just wondering do you
do you think there was selection for
kind of fruit specific alterations
these genes may be more highly expressed
yeah yeah good good question so are are
these genes
um expressed uh elsewhere in the plant
and or maybe in the hypotypes that uh
that don't express these genes at all in
the fruit yeah we've we've looked at
that in um in public databases so it's
it looks like this Locus is very food
specific
um meaning that you know especially Mass
3 is just not all anywhere except for
you know breaker stage and then ripe is
very high and then mess one is expressed
a little bit higher earlier on but it
goes up
um during ripening
um yeah mass2 we have actually not found
expression of that in any of the tissues
in public database so I don't know what
mass2 is doing mess four is also kind of
Hit or Miss so I don't know we we are
working with a group in Knoxville
Tennessee uh Fang Chen and he's
interested in uh
um in methyl salicylate in root and
leaves and so they've been quantifying
this collection for methyl salicylate
levels in the roots and uh and the
leaves so once we get there
you know they want to share the data
with us so we can run it through the
gbos pipeline and we'll see if the same
Locus contributes to methyl salicylate
levels in in other parts of the plant
yeah
you would be um talking to a breeder
about reducing methodology levels and
fruit would you rather recommend pushing
the pathway upwards just towards
salicylic acid or downwards towards the
glycoside glycosylated conversions yeah
you get their trade-off yeah so if if
the plant is
um uh you know methyl salicylate level
still can go up in those that produce
very low levels if the plant is attacked
for example so there's all the
mechanisms to turn to turn on the
production of you know salicylic acid
the methyl salicylate so for breeders
what I would recommend functional uh at
nsdt1 and a functional appropriate
admissible as well
so mess Locus is largely selected
already in the germplasm but if you were
to make crosses to you know wild
relatives or so for disease resistance
or other traits you want to make sure
you get the right HEPA type of mess uh
in there
yeah so that's what we could tell
breeders in this case so this is a
little simpler story but there's still
variation out there that we cannot
explain so there's still more out there
to be mined
thank you everyone
foreign
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu